hi I'm Jimmy Kimmel I'm going undercover
in the internet and this is actually me
[Music]
Cora why are Jimmy Kimmel and Matt Damon
rivals
we're not rivals we're enemies Magic
Johnson Larry Bird were rivals this is
more I have filled in with coy type
situation with him being McCoy posted is
Jimmy Kimmel middle eastern I'm
primarily Italian but I do indeed have
some middle-eastern in me which explains
my love of hummus submitted next up I am
DB trivia Jimmy Kimmel was a wedding DJ
for three years absolutely true in
Phoenix Arizona when I was in college I
worked as a wedding DJ since dr. oz told
him to he eats a bar of dark chocolate
every day that is not true and also says
I have phallus of phobia a fear of
oceans I wouldn't say I have a fear of
oceans I have a fear of tidal waves
I had recurring nightmares about tidal
waves and I guess they come out of the
ocean so if technically that is a fear
of oceans I'll go along with it but I
will go swim in the ocean
I'll urinate in the ocean you name it
I'll do in the ocean I'm not scared of
the ocean here's something that I think
should be an IMDB once there was a rat
in my house and instead of setting a
trap for the rat like normal people
would do I had a pellet gun and I set up
a commando station about 30 feet away
from the cabinet where the rat was
living and I shot off my whole kitchen
didn't get the right way not even close
it would just go by in a flash I thought
I was like Luke Skywalker shooting womp
rats or something but it turns out I'm
no Luke Skywalker Twitter oh this is
interesting watching a paranormal video
on YouTube and this popped up Jimmy
Kimmel is this you lol and there's I
guess a ghost you know it's funny
because usually when people compare
other people to me I'm insulted I got
like I don't look like that guy but this
ghost is actually better looking than I
am so thanks posted how much of Jimmy
Kimmel's beard is eyebrow pencil eyebrow
pencils beard pencil whereas they do
paint the bald spot in on my head
I refuse on religious reasons to have my
beard drawn in it's actually me ugh why
is jimmy kimmel hosting the Oscars again
this year
oh thanks tdawg91 oh the answer they
asked me certainly not for money
submit has anyone ever noticed how
incredibly sexy Jimmy Kimmel is I need
to start watching his show more the guy
has one hell of a mug you know all
talk-show hosts have mugs it's like kind
of a standard thing mine says the view
on it but thank you I really do
appreciate that Jimmy Kimmel what's the
most expensive pair of shoes you own
you're wealthy but where's the line
between practical and eccentric
curiosity I do have a pair of boots that
I've had for like nine or ten years that
cost $600 which seemed ridiculous at the
time but I feel like I got my money's
worth out of them answers.com
was Jimmy Kimmel bitten by a rattlesnake
on one of his shows kind of we had an
animal trainer on I thought it would be
funny to have a robotic snake bite me
and pretend that it was real and the box
springs open and the rattlesnake bites
me and I pretend to go down and medics
come in they load me into the back of an
ambulance and they take me to the
hospital on Grey's Anatomy at which
point I thought people would understand
it was joke but a lot of people didn't
think it was a joke and they were all
mad at me
which I understand enter do the ancestor
of Jimmy Kimmel come from easkey ah that
is correct and most of our family was
killed in an earthquake there in the
late 1800s two of them survived the
legend goes that they were at a play
about an earthquake in a newly built
arena and in fact it was a newly built
is the only reason that it remains
standing and so that play about an
earthquake saved my family from an
earthquake read it does anyone know how
to get a job working at Jimmy Kimmel
Live yeah some people do we have a lot
of people who work here my
great-grandmother looks exactly like
Jimmy Kimmel and I am gonna say that
other than the beard this does look just
like me I do look like this person's
great-grandma what if this is another of
Kimmel's pranks like he went back in
time and cosplay as your grandma for
this photo and came
to the future and convincing that was
your boy if I had the power to travel
through time that is how I'd use it but
in this case I didn't officially on
vennett Wikipedia it's actually me
Kimmel was born in Brooklyn New York
correct grew up in the neighborhood of
Mill Basin correct eldest of three
children of Joan high Cano correct a
homemaker and James John Kimmel and IBM
executive actually who worked for
American Express for most of his career
but yes let me flesh this out a little
big I do have two siblings my brother
Jonathan who works here on the show as a
director my sister is a comedian her
name is Jill Kimmel I have a son Kevin
who works on the show as a production
assistant and I have a daughter named
Katie who is a ceramics artist and in
fact she makes funny ceramics and
drawings and paintings I also have a
three-year-old daughter named Jane and
an eight month old son named Billy you
probably know who that one is in our
family we value humor definitely more
than cleanliness and when you make
somebody laugh in our family they'll
stop yelling at you for a few minutes
submitted for your approval next Yahoo
Answers why did I dream I was Jimmy
Kimmel
it's weird I dreamt I was Jimmy Kimmel I
can't figure out why what could this
mean
then I watch too much TV maybe every
actually changed perspective during a
dream it might mean that you need
medication that should definitely see
somebody if that really did happen
you're sick does Clay Aiken really have
the tattoo of Jimmy Kimmel on his leg no
he does not really have a tattoo of me
on his leg that was a bit we did we drew
that on with a pen maybe he got one
since then I don't know more Wikipedia
Kimmel guest hosted live with Regis and
Kelly during the week of October 22nd
through 26 2007 commuting every day
between New York and LA in the process
he broke the Guinness world record for
the longest distance traveled in one
work week 22400 six miles now I do hold
the Guinness world record for longest
distance traveled in a workweek but
there's no way that I'm even in the top
100 a president has definitely topped
this or maybe a prime minister maybe a
pope no way I beat the Pope more Twitter
Jimmy Kimmel how would you react if Matt
Damon really downsized
have the house sprayed an official Leo
you PRC asks hey Jimmy Kimmel I like how
you give celebrities a chance to guest
host your shows what can or do I have to
do to host the show also it's not like
people are lining up wanting to guest
host my show I was out with my family in
the hospital that week but if I'm out
again
will I let Leo host JK oh yes not this
leo maybe a Leo DiCaprio may be the
Uncle Leo from Seinfeld but probably not
this leo sorry leo Jimmy Kimmel why is
it that one fat funny guys lose weight
they stop being funny did you lose your
funny camel when you lost the weight I
guess so yeah YouTube this is the
comments section on YouTube which is a
place I never go this is really dumb but
am I the only one who thought cousin Sal
wasn't Jimmy's actual cousin but rather
a character played by full House's Dave
Coulier I wish my cousin was Dave
Coulier I really do but my cousin Sal
really is my cousin he actually got his
law degree and I convinced him to quit
that and come out to LA he's not that
bright so he agreed to do it and now
here we are many years later why does
Jimmy have a random bass clarinet I
started playing the clarinet when I was
in the sixth grade I wanted to play the
trombone but I thought trombones were
called clarinets I got the class and
they're all playing like this I said no
no I'm supposed to be in the clarinet
class the teacher I remember left really
hard so I just decided I'd played the
clarinet so I keep one in my office I
play it from time to time submitted
what's Jimmy short for jimothy yeah
jimothy so that's it that's everything
there is to know about me I don't have
to write a book now I've answered all
the questions every mystery has been
revealed to you you are the only person
watching this that's me